darüber müssen wir sprechen das ist eins
der meist gegoogelt worte natürlich in
den letzten wochen trockenheit natürlich
ganz genauso und die frage in schwann
regnet es endlich wieder deutschland
trocknet aus immer weiter diese woche ja
wieder hitze und bundesweit kaum regen
wir schon mal auf diese dürre karte
deutschlands ja so trocken ist es
überall um uns herum die roten stellen
in deutschland die dann schon ein dealer
werden daher sind die trockensten stelle
das ist deutschland in diesem jahr
deutschlands flüsse und seen trocknen
langsam aus die schwarze elster in
brandenburg oder die panke in berlin
kaum wasser auch an rhein main und
neckar sinken die pegel bedrohlich
deutschland braucht dringend wasser wenn
das nicht bald kommt dann hat das
drastische folgen nicht nur für die
natur auch für die wirtschaft denn wegen
des niedrigwassers im rhein müssen die
binnenschiffe ihr gewicht reduzieren
das heißt sie dürfen nicht mehr so viel
transportieren die folge weniger kohle
futtergetreide mineralöl- und metaller
wieder mal wieder explodierende preise
experten befürchten dass bald der
schiffsverkehr auf dem rhein vollständig
zum erliegen kommt die auswirkungen der
hitze sind im ganzen land spürbar berlin
die spree bekommt nicht genug wasser
fließt nun rückwärts die elbe ist an
einigen stellen so ausgetrocknet dass
kein schiff mehr fahren darf baden
württemberg drastisch sinkende
wasserstände auch im südwesten an 80
prozent der pegel liegen die werte
unterhalb des niedrigsten wasserstandes
in einem durchschnittlichen jahr
die wochenlange trockenheit macht auch
den karpfen teilchen den bayern zu
schaffen diese mussten zum teil not
abgefischt werden weil die teiche
ausgetrocknet sind
ja sommer ist ja schön aber diese dürre
die macht dann schon einige probleme
unser wetter experte karsten brandt ist
der schüler und jugend a castilla gab es
so etwas schon mal
also es gab natürlich schon in den
letzten 100 jahren immer wieder mal
sommer jahre mit klima trockenheit 1947
da wenn sich nur natürlich weniger daran
erinnern nach dem zweiten weltkrieg ein
sehr heftiges trocken ja da war der
einzige auch sehr sehr niedrig wir
hatten dann 1976 eine große trockenheit
in deutschland auch extreme probleme bei
der in der landwirtschaft man konnte
keine hand also also das kommt immer
wieder vor aber was wir jetzt erleben
ist
wirklich der so der höhepunkt eine
extreme dürre
wirklich kaum zu steigern so etwas habe
ich persönlich nicht erlebt uns kommt
ist deshalb auch so erklären da wir bei
dieses jahr große trockenheit haben aber
schon 2018 2019 zwei trocken jahre
hinter uns hatten und all das zusammen
mit dass hintereinander in so kurzer
zeit führt zu diesem großen wassermengen
also drei mal drei jahre hintereinander
sind dann einfach nur viel und führen zu
diesen bildern die man ja gerade im
hinterkopf also wir werden mehr und mehr
zu italien zum mittelitalien heißt es
auch wir müssen komplett unsere
wirtschaft darauf umstellen also
sozusagen wie die italiener vor zwanzig
vor 30 40 jahren unsere landwirtschaft
so pflegen wie die italiener alles
umdenken
letztendlich also wie wir ich nenne das
gerne städten klima was wir so ein
bisschen bekommen denn die trockenheit
im sommer die wird ganz dominieren das
hat man im mittelmeerraum ja auch gerade
diese dieser extreme trockenheit manche
jahre sind nass dann ein zwei jahre
wieder trocken dann wieder nass ist ja
also diese wechsel auch darauf müssen
wir uns besser besser vorbereiten und
natürlich mit steigenden temperaturen
das richtig magath
zeigen wir werden jetzt aktuell hier
noch angenehme 20 grad wo ich hier
draußen stehen aber nachher sind 30 grad
wir kriegen am wochenende wieder 35 wir
haben steigende temperaturen und
deswegen wirklich die im vergleich mit
italien ist nicht schlecht weil man
einfach die klima werte aus italien der
achtziger neunziger jahre jetzt in
deutschland haben und das bedeutet dass
wir auch mehr wasser verdunsten also in
der landwirtschaft müssen wir mehr
wasser einsetzen ihrem verbrauch
meerwasser oder meerwasser geht aus den
seen aus den speicherbecken verloren und
ich möchte das auch zeigen also eine
gießkanne ladung flitter die im garten
benutze das verdunstet an so einem tag
und wenn wir höhere temperaturen haben
dann geht quasi pro jahr 50 liter also
zehnmal solche solche gießkannen ladung
im jahr zusätzlich verloren und darauf
müssen wir uns hier in deutschland
einstellen also es wird extrem trockener
wir müssen mit stecken klima rechnen und
wir müssen auch die wälder umbauen dass
die bäume das vertrag also wird sich
kein hinweis verändern in deutschland
auf lange sicht kassen dran der
wetterexperte vielen herzlichen dank
und das mit der gag an der phan thi
kahle total beeindruckend einmal ganz
anschaulich so vieler so eine 5 liter
gießkanne am tag
verdunstet im moment in deutschland bei
dieser hitze bei dieser enormen
trockenheit wir schalten mal durch die
trockene republik deutschland und fang
an bei unserer bild reporterin bianca
weiner in emmerich also am ufer des
rheins bianca schilder uns einmal so
wenig rein wie gerade jetzt war noch nie
ja das ist richtig aktuell ist der
pegelstand hierbei 20 cm das ist schon
dramatisch weil es gab bisher in der
geschichte hier des rheins erst ein
tieferen stand er dabei sieben
zentimeter das war 2018 normalerweise
ist das wasser man kann unten schauen
das wasser des rheins bis hier oben
und jetzt sieht man wie tief das wasser
schon runter gegangen ist der rhein ist
hier an dieser stelle 300 meter aktuell
breit und normalerweise ist der 500
meter breit also m die experten ich habe
gerade mit der wasserschutzpolizei
gesprochen sie rechnen auch damit dass
dieser dramatische wert von 7 zentimeter
auch noch überschritten wird weil der
rest der woche auch noch weiterhin heiß
sein werde also der reihe der macht sich
hier dünner vielen herzlichen dank ihren
berufen rüber zu jonathan andere auch er
am rhein in bingen am mäuseturm
eigentlich muss man im schiffchen rüber
jetzt aber sieht man dass sich auch dort
der rhein ganz schön dünnem 8 jonathan
erklären es einmal die situation bei dir
ja es ist ab so patricia ich stehe hier
mitten im rhein so kann man das
eigentlich formulieren und stehe
eigentlich hier auf dem ausgetrockneten
flussbett im rhein er hinter mir ist der
mäuseturm das war ein ehemaliger
wachturm der war mal dazu gedacht die
schiffe zu kontrollieren soll
einzufordern und war eigentlich dazu da
um in mitte der in der mitte des rheins
von rechts und links die schiffe zu
kontrollieren also man sieht links
können längst schon keine schiffe mehr
durchfahren man kann sogar die mäuse
insel auf der der turm steht
mittlerweile zu fuß überqueren und ja
sind ganz dramatische ausmaße die hier
zu tage kommen wegen der dürre am rhein
das also im rhein und in allen teilchen
in deutschland auch bei annika rage
unser bild reporterin die sind peter
sein bei görlitz und da geht's um fisch
aktuell annika
genau karsten brandt hat es ja eben
schon gesagt die umstände sind extrem
und extrem ist es auch hier ich möchte
es euch einmal zeigen was hitze und
ausbleibender regen eigentlich für
einfluss auf flora und fauna so zu sagen
haben und auf unsere teiche wir schauen
hier nämlich mal runter ich stehe ihr
könnt es wahrscheinlich nicht glauben
mitten im teich
eigentlich denn ich stehe eigentlich im
trockenen und eigentlich wäre dieser
teich eben 120 tief ich bin jetzt hier
mit dem fisch wert wird kittler und ich
wollte sie jetzt einmal 65 tage hier und
die situation könnte aktuell für sie
nicht schlimmer sein mit welchen
problemen haben sich hier geradezu
kämpfen ja also aktuell ist es so wir
haben in fast allen unseren teichen in
akuten wassermangel bedingt durch
ausgebliebene niederschläge speziell im
frühjahr aber auch den ganzen sommer und
dieses problem wird jeden tag ein bis
zwei zentimeter schlimmer weil die teile
so viel pro tag abnehmen sie können
einmal ganz gezeigt werden jetzt echt
ein allgemeiner weise wäre der
wasserstand in dem teich so hoch wie der
zollstock ist bisher sie hat also hier
akut in dem aktuell sehr sehr schwierig
dem erzählt sie haben hier 270.000
fische drin karpfen die sie zum verzehr
verkaufen wie blicken sie jetzt auf
dieses jahr haben sie haben sie angst
dass diese fische hier sterben können
also hier ist ständig mit verlusten zu
rechnen weil der wasserstand einfach
keine bedingung mehr bietet es ist mit
sauerstoffmangel täglich zu rechnen
aufgrund des wenig was heißt dann sitzen
die frisch auf zu engem raum dass sie
sich gegenseitig
natürlich auch in ihren
lebensbedingungen beeinträchtigen und
das sind alles probleme die hier zur
seite stehen auch der zuwachs fällt
natürlich die konditionen die sich für
den winter anpassen können ist weg also
das ist eine ganz verzwickte sache ja
ich habe jetzt auch videos gesehen in
denen fische praktisch fast an der
oberfläche schwimmen weil sie einfach
eben nicht mehr diesen dieses tiefe
wasser zur verfügung haben wie groß ist
ihre sorge wie gut schlafen sie dann
noch da schläft man nicht mehr gut in
das schlimmste ist wenn man in der
morgendämmerung ausgeht und dann
überlegt wo vor ich zuerst gucken wo
könnte das größte problem sein weil man
muss täglich damit rechnen dass die
fische an sauerstoffmangel umkippen und
dann steht man war es ist also nicht
einfach hier diese fische die in der
größe sind abzufischen
das ist fast unmöglich das alles
lebendig raus zu kriegen eine letzte
frage sie haben wie gesagt 65 teiche mit
regen kann man eigentlich gerade nicht
rechnen wie lange wie lange halten sie
und wie lange halten ihre fiche das
überhaupt noch aus also das ist jetzt
eine sache wo man sagen muss man täglich
mit dem schlimmsten rechnen es ist nicht
schön wenn man sowas sagen muss aber da
keine rettung in sicht ist wasser gibt
es keins kann man nur hoffen
bestehen bleibt es trocken bleibt sorgen
ja okay und damit gebe ich zurück nach
berlin wie ihr seht von diesem teich
bleibt immer weniger übrig und das gilt
für gesamtdeutschland
vielen herzlichen dank annika vielen
herzlichen dank an unsere reporterinnen
und reporter mit diesem einblicke so
geht deutschland mit der dürre derzeit
um probleme gibt es natürlich an allen
ecken und enden
[Musik]